Even though it's loose, it's just one color, so
you can't call it a veil, so why not
?  From the white side
[music]
me
ana Stir-fried thinly sliced ​​onions
Melt the fresh Kripalmesan cheese Mix the eggs and melted butter together
to make
cheese  2
Japan's fine line
Sugar exchange where?
You don't mean to eat without thinking, right? Then why don't
you try it yourself?
I asked for cheese and the army melted tightly It was
delicious and I
hit it What's wrong with the chest spoon?
After
increasing the light scent of these ingredients, I mixed
them with Sformart and chopped each material into 0.1 mm increments with Netza Luna to the optimum size.
The bitterness and aroma
function to eliminate the odor, and I regret the two tastes.